which Pixar family favorite is drawing
comparisons to HBO's brutal Survival
series The Last of Us if you've seen
episode 3 you already know and you
probably ran out of tissues
at first glance there's little in common
between the fun family-friendly Pixar
film up and the Grim post-apocalyptic
series The Last of Us One features a
giant flightless bird named Kevin while
the other features a broken man who's
willing to hurt others to protect his
surrogate daughter that is until episode
3. no no birds named Kevin show up but
the majority of the episode takes a
break from Joel and Ellie's journey to
tell the Love Story between Bill and
Frank showing them growing old and
eventually dying together much like how
the opening Montage of op tells the
story of two people falling in love and
growing old together with one of them
dying in both cases it's a beautiful
heartbreaking story that will leave even
the most hardened viewers teary-eyed in
the game we only see Frank after he has
already died having been bitten by an
infected and choosing to hang himself
rather than turn Once Upon a Time
I had somebody that I cared about
partner
however we get to see to see Bill meets
Frank and then the show cuts to
different stages of their life together
before Frank becomes terminally ill
leading both to take a lethal dose of
pills online a lot of viewers are
comparing the tragic but beautiful story
of Bill and Frank to that of Carl and
his wife Ellie and up on Reddit one user
wrote I turned to my wife mid-sab while
we were watching and yelled how did I
get tricked into watching the first five
minutes of up again on Twitter one fan
posted The Last of Us episode 3 is an
amazing short story akin to the opening
of up just humans finding meaning within
the greater struggle sharing a similar
sentiment another fan wrote The Last of
Us episode 3 was seriously incredible a
heartbreaking love story that reminds me
of that opening scene and up except
somehow Bleaker just beautiful the
comparison between The Last of Us
episode 3 and Pixar's Up goes beyond
both telling a poignant and tragic love
story they also both depict the
importance of actually living life
rather than merely surviving
paying attention to things
it's how we show love
in The Last of Us Bill initially sets
out to simply survive the apocalypse
when he meets up with Joel and Tess he
actually refers to himself as a
survivalist however something changed
when he met Frank suddenly he's not just
alone in the world trying to avoid
getting bitten by the infected he has
someone to look out for and who has his
back as evidenced when Bill defends the
town against Raiders and the reason he's
able to survive his gunshot wound is
that Frank was there to care for him up
goes in a slightly different order but
the same message is there Carl isn't
really living after he loses Ellie but
after he gets swept up in an adventure
to South America to fulfill a promise he
made to his late wife both stories
exhibit the profound truth that life can
get lonely if you choose to go It Alone
lives are meant to be shared with the
people closest to us and that's a
message Joel still needs to learn in The
Last of Us
foreign